il est 20h6 on est en direct on va
passer au débat du jour et un maire
refuse de donner un chèque de Noël à la
famille d'un hmetier comprenez-vous
cette décision alors oui non c'est le
débat du jour vous y allez on vous fait
un petit récap et le maire en question
sera avec nous juste après c'est Didier
gonzalz regardez lu FC Porto regardez
c'est parti pas de chèque de Noël cette
année pour la famille d'un nmetier à
villeeneuve Leroi le jeune homme a été
condamné à 12 mois de prison avec surcis
il avait participé à la dégradation du
poste de de police pendant les émeutes
de juin dernier après la mort de Naël
alors pas question pour le maire de lui
faire profiter du chèque de Noël
l'individu âgé de 19 ans habite toujours
chez ses parents contacté par RTL le
jeune homme a affirmé n'avoir rien cassé
et s'être simplement retrouvé à
proximité du commissariat il s'est dit
prêt à rencontrer le maire pour tenter
de le convaincre de revenir sur la
sanction bonsoir Didier gonzalz merci
d'être avec nous merci merci vous êtes
maire de ville le roi vous avez refusé
donc d'offrir ce chèque à la famille de
ce jeune homme alors oui non vous vous
réagissez également chez vous il est
20h8 on est en direct qui pense que
c'est une une bonne voilà une bonne
décision pourquoi vous l'avez fait en
fait ben c'est très simple au mois de
juin la la mairie de ville neuvelerois a
été incendiée le CCA c'estàdire le le
Centre Communal d'Action Sociale est
parti en fumée comme vous le voyez et le
lendemain il y a eu une attaque du poste
de police et lors de cette attaque du
poste de police une première porte a été
fracturée ils ont versé de
l'essence à l'intérieur du local et
c'est été un miracle
que les les agents de police ne brûlent
puisque en définitive la BAC est arrivé
une extrémiste et ça permis de de
d'empêcher ce drame et donc logiquement
quand j'ai vu que cette
famille demandait une aide une aide de
Noël qu'on fait une petite aide en
réalité c'est 60 € 60 € pour tro
personnes hein bon puisque la
composition familiale c'est trois
personnes hein donc le père la mère et
le fils et donc dans ce dans ce cadre là
quand on a vu ça on s'est dit c'est
c'est pas possible vu la gravité des des
éléments et je tiens à préciser que ce
n'est pas une aide une aide légale une
aide prévue par l'État c'est
une signe qui est donné par la
municipalité pour pour accompagner à
l'occasion de Noël donc il est majeur le
jeune pour vous ses parents doivent-ils
doivent payer encore les les
conséquences de de ces actes mais c'est
toute la famille il se trouve dans le
cercle familial alors certes il est tout
jeune majeur mais il n'empêche que il se
trouve dans le cercle de responsabilité
de la famille parce que c'est trop
facile de venir postuler pour les droits
oui ouais exactement ils sont à tro
alors c'est très facile de postuler pour
les droits et pour les devoirs à ce
momentl il se retrouve tout seul quoi he
donc il y a il y a un petit un petit
souci de responsabilité dans tout ça
donc voilà alors euh on va voir qui est
d'accord avec Monsieur le Maire
Géraldine euh oui moi moi je pense que
effectivement à part les humanistes ici
qui ont un grand cœur moi je trouve que
ça ça ça mérite quand même d'être d'être
essayé je vois pas pourquoi et à quel
titre on vandalise les mairies on brûle
les drapeau on vandalise les écoles les
commissariats et comme ça en toute
impunité et je trouve que c'est malgré
tout un bon signale puisqueà partir du
moment où il est il a 19 ans mais il n'a
rien eu au final il a eu du surcis avec
un ouais c'est ça du surcis un stage qui
fera ou qui fera pas et qui servira de
toute façon à rien donc de toute façon
voilà donc je trouve que c'est quand
même un bon signal de dire en gros aux
parents ben en fait vous êtes
responsable de vos enfants et aux
enfants et quand vous faites de la merde
en fait et ben vos parents payent le
truc et je trouve que c'est bien quand
ils sont
mineurs c'est pour ça quand sous le toit
de sous le toit de ses parents moi je
trouve excusez-moi je vois pas en quoi
vandaliser des écoles il est des
commissariats je vois pas quel est le
rapport avec la mort de naë en fait donc
c'est juste des ordes de sauvag et donc
on les punit et on leur montre de quoi
il s'agit vous êtes d'accord ave ce que
VI de dire oui oui bien sûr je suis
d'accord et en plus c'est un dispositif
qui est complètement différent quoi on
est on est dans une petite aide pour
payer un un cadeau de Noël un cadeau de
Noël à la hauteur de 60 € très
franchement c'est
pas
symb le symbo important aprs il y aura
Valée ben non c'est pas un truc de fou
ce que je vais dire mais on peut prouver
il y a pas que des trucs de fou qui sont
dit dans cette émission mais pour moi il
y a encore une histoire de logique un
petit peu enfin la personne elle a 19
ans on connait pas leur vie on sait même
pas si il est tout le temps chez ses
parents s'il y est pas sa pas
comment é condamné par jus on sa pas si
découche si s'il est vraiment encadré si
ses parents sont pas au bout du rouleau
justement de de vivre ça et ils en
peuvent plus le
enfant mais non mais il a rien qui je
suis pas du tout en train de justifier
qu'on qu'on brûle une école je suis
juste en train de justifier les parents
ils sont peut-être le désar tot et
j'aurais préféré qu'on envoie cette
personne en prison s'il faut voilà s'il
mérite la prison il va en prison mais
qu'on pénalise pas les parents qui sont
sûrement au bout du rouleau et on sait
même pas si leur fille leur fils il
découche pas s'il vivent vraiment avec
eux ce qui vous dérange c'est qu'il soit
majeur exactement il est majeur et je
pense que c'est
person j'aimerais bien avoir la réponse
de Didier gonzalz mais non mais
justement mais prison s'il le faut mais
c'est très bien il est majeur et condamé
alors c'est pas lui c'est personne donc
c'est
pas c'est lui donc on sait que c'est lui
puisqu'il est il est majeur et condamné
on sait lui a-t-il est-ce qu'il y a une
excuse de minorité non donc très bien il
est pleinement responsable est-ce que il
a une composition familiale difficile
mère isolée et cetera abandonnner et
tout pas du tout parents euh normal
enfin situation familiale normale on a
juste eu des gens qui savent se
retrouver en famille pour bénéficier TR
fois de 20 € en revanche ça c'est en
matière de droit et en matière de devoir
à ce momentl on s'isole
complètement nor
pour Gonzalez c'est qu'il vit chez ses
parents donc s
par
ons
est ok faut pas moi je vais avoir le
sondage j'aim bien qu'on voit déjà un
petit peu le sondage là s'il vous plaît
pour voir si j'ai raison voilà je
comprends cette décision je suis à 94%
d'accord voilà je suis d'accord avec le
public alors vas-y dis tes trucs et puis
tu vois bien que tu es un
loser merci c'est encourageant non mais
Monsieur le Maire ça n'a pas de sens il
a 19 ans il a été condamné il a un stage
de citoyenneté qu'il va payer et
lui-même dit je veux voir le maire je
veux payer moi je veux payer je veux
payer mais laiss laisser à ma mère petit
chèque pourquoi Vous sanctionnez cette
mère de famille exemplaire parce que son
fils a fauté fait vite ouais ben écoutez
c'est pas compliqué je l'attends
toujours cet hmetier voyez j'ai invité
seule la maman est venue on l'a toujours
pas et d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'il a dit
dans un autre média il a dit que de
toute façon il ferait jamais le travail
d'intérêt général alors que justement
nous lui demandons de venir pour qu' il
démarre un commencement de réparation
alors que pensez-vous de
l'ENS des vill qui cotisent qui pay qui
eux se lèvent le matin et ne cassent pas
ne brûl pas ne commettent pas ces actes
de sauvagerie vous voulez payer
qu'est-ce que vous voulez lui offrir un
cadeau de Noël peut-être peut-être un
mortier ou une
barre non ça c'est pas bien il a été
condamné en jus'a il pas été
condamné civil pas au civille pas au
civil c'est-àdire que la réparation de
sa peine il ne l'a fait pas vis-à-vis de
la ville pas just mon ma moi moi je
trouve que le maire a tout à fait raison
il est temps il est temps que la peur
change de camp tu peux pas à la fois
brûler des équipements publics et en
même temps ensuite derrière profiter d'A
de l'état de la collectivité non mais
attends je suis
désolé es quand tu es pas un exemple
pour la société je vois pas pourquoi la
société t'aiderait pas pas lui c'est la
famille la
fam
log question logique de donant donant il
faut rétablir l'idée du donnant
donnantpr monsieur dit quelque chose
làant par exemple le monsieur vient de
dire monsieur vient de dire que la maman
s'est présentée et que son fils n'est
pas venu on voit bien donc elle est
dépassé cette maman donc c'est la double
peine pour c'est bien pour ça que je
pense qu'il faut rétablir le donnant
donnant tu aides la société et bien
c'est normal que on t'aide ensuite mais
lorsque ça n'est pas le cas je suis
désolé
pas pas seulement une question argument
que le monsieur a donnéou BO qu'on a pas
eu avant qu'est-ce que vous voulez c'est
que cet argent là le monsieur a dit en
fait c'est l'argent pour aider les
parents à acheter un cadeau à leurant on
savait pas dès le début ça voilà si
c par a écoutez pas Monsieur G nécoutez
pas non mais vous restez logique c'est
on dit que c'est une prime de Noël
d'abord que Monsieur décide de donner
indépendamment de l'État moi je suis
d'accord que si tu casses à un moment
donné il y a une jurisprudence si tu
casses faudra bien punir à un moment
donné le gars à 19 ans il s'est fait
punir par la justice donc il est
coupable c'est une prime de Noël les
noms là c'est une prime de Noël c'est
pour qui Noël pour les enfants c'est une
prime de Noël il y a qu'un enfant donc
c'est pour lui la prime anun
[Musique]
enfant Noël c'est pour les
enfants soz
log si vous donnez une prime à quelqu'un
qui a tout cassé et tu vas dire aux gens
après qui sont dans cette villeel voyez
vos impôts il servent à ce qu'on P
me la symbolique c'est jurisprudence
pour est symbol pas
lesut des mairies on va prendre sur la
prime de Noël réfléchissez bien prend
prends pas le problème à l'envers tu
prends le problème à l'envers de dire la
symbolique la discrimination et C et ce
il a été dans lesmetiers il a brûlé une
maie il a famille TR les indivit au lie
de CR familles de délinqus qui
vont pour pas 20 € ça part lui c'est pas
grave il y a pas
de problème le problème c'est le mec de
19 ans il a eu un problème ses parents
il vont
neries le 31 décembre il a encore eu 800
ou 900 voiture qu'on brûlé tout ça c'est
avec votre discours angélique où on les
gens sont jamais condamnés les gens
continuent de toucher des aides moi je
suis désolé mais un moment donné il faut
aller plus loin ils s'en foutent ils
savent que ce seraon ah oui et toi tu
trouves normal que ce soit tes impôts
qui payent à la fois la reconstruction
et moi pas je suis désolé je trouve ça
absolument scandale Alley V merci papa
euh Monsieur le Maire moi je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous dans le
sens où il faut punir il faut punir
sévèrement mais on peut pas être juge et
parti il a été condamné par par la
justice alors effectivement la
condamnation elle est vraiment minime
elle est quasiment nulle mais je ne
pense pas que les parents soient attends
je ne pense pas que les parents soient
responsables de de leur fils majeur
pourquoi il y a deux éducations il y a
l'éducation de la maison quand l'enfant
arrive à la maison il est super gentil
avec les parents et compagn et quand il
est dans la rue et ben il fait des
conneries comme ça et je pense que c'est
à la justice de faire son travail et
effectiv ement je pense que la maman qui
s'est déplacé chez vous je pense que
vous aurez dû le laisser le cadeau de de
Noël et elle vous a dit quoi cette maman
ben dans un premier temps elle a nié
d'accord et puis après elle est bien été
obligée de reconnaître puisque je lui
dis écoutez il s'est fait condamner
c'est bien
luioui bon et et après bah oui mais
voilà mais voilà bah voilà voilà pour
vous ça pas le
fait et donc quand j'ai vu dans la
presse que il était pas a décidé à faire
les travaux d'intérêts généraux hein que
nous nous essayons de programmer pour
pour voir la ville au sujet de la ville
donc là à ce moment-là je lui dis mais
il va falloir qu'on se revoie pour qu'il
effectue ses travaux d'intérêt généraux
enfin c'est c'est c'est c'est quand même
le minimum du minimum donc voilà alors
si vous voulez de toute façon
l'enveloppe est assez limité d'accord ça
concerne 60 familles si on pense si on
pense que effectivement il faut lui
donner
et quelquun qui va trouver juste limite
lui va Pasir alte bien
et on va
PIR je vois pas pourquoi on va on va
quasiment
encourager ce type
chose
leagesieurz regardez vous avez raison
94%ot de toute
façon faut aller encore plus
vite
comprre
bien merci à vous allez on va revenir
sur l'amour et dans le Pr merci bravo à
vous on va revenir sur l'amour